it's not the writer's job to tell the
director how
to make the story most the most
compelling it can be
so the writers of homeland
they didn't want to change it or
it just they felt that the way it was
written was fine the two sisters well
this this opens up a lot of questions
which i think are really
features of
collaborative creativity that i find
fascinating they had written the script
and felt good about it they thought it
worked in a certain way and they they
told me the way they thought it worked
but it's so interesting you know in
features generally i think
in general terms feet and features the
director is more the one empowered to
kind of make a lot of the creative
decisions in series television it's
weighted much more towards the writer
and the show runner so that
so that
the interesting challenge in coming into
a series is i have to be serving the
vision of the show runner i can't change
that it's not that's not my place
but i can bring but but but what's
interesting is that
the writer has to
would be better off i think if they
acknowledge
we'll certainly get greater creative
contributions from others if they
acknowledge that their work has to be
interpreted
a script is really a fleshless blueprint
when you think about it it's words on a
page uh you know i mean i say in the
book it's like there's no such thing as
filming the script that would be
pictures of words on the page you have
to you know you have to interpret it you
have to give
the actors have to bring their
understanding of what's going on you
have to dig deep for the kinds of inner
life and subtext and intentions that
i've been describing
um and it's not really the writers
the writer delivers a script that they
felt good about which is in this case
they did and and and it turned out to be
great
now
i gave it a subtext and an inner life
that they hadn't imagined
but what fascinates me is
i wouldn't have arrived at my
understanding of what the scene could be
if the script had been written any
differently i looked at the speech
maggie gives
and she references her pain from
childhood
and that was a way that
my experience in life my understanding
of how human beings work led me to bring
my again bring my own experience to it
to ask to explore myself
what those kind of issues and words
evoked and they evoked me the
possibility that that may not just be in
the past it might be now also so without
a word changing
i came to that understanding and it was
a clue embedded in the dialogue itself
which the writers did not did not
consider consciously was even there
but i i believe and there's another
chapter i write on the uh an episode of
the americans
uh where a very similar total
transformation happened without changing
a word in that chapter i call rewriting
the subtext
the homeland chapter i call making
meaning which is really what i felt i
was doing
uh it's not it's not the writer's job to
tell the director how
to make the story most the most
compelling it can be
the writer provides a script that they
feel good about that's what these
writers did
it's my job
to interpret it and to
translate it in a way that feels pers
that feels meaningful to me that i
believe the audience is going to
respond to
uh so
that's one thing i really value about
series television directing is the
limitations i'm given because
you know it's like it's like
like a feature with unlimited budget if
you can't do something it's easy to
solve a problem by throwing money at it
or giving more days to shoot or whatever
but when you have limitations often that
can inspire creative solutions because
you know sometimes we take the path of
least resistance well the only way to do
that is to shoot two extra days or you
know to have a thousand extra extras or
whatever you know but wait you can't oh
so how can i solve it another way uh
there's a story i tell in the book too
it may be apocryphal but i it's funny i
was an assistant director for francis
coppola but this is a story about
francis
that i'd heard that you know there's a
in godfather 2
when young vito comes to ellis island
uh there's a very iconic shot of well
before i tell about that shot
uh the story anyway is that francis
wanted to
film uh
build a set that would be for ellis
island that would somewhere look out on
the statue of liberty so that you could
have young veto staring out of the
statue of liberty well that was
impossible and budget didn't allow for
it so the solution that they came up
with was to have young veto come to the
window
and stare out and in the glass there was
a reflection of the statue of liberty
which was a picture of the statue of
liberty a backing you know and that was
a beautiful poetic image you united in
one image the statue of liberty and the
face of young veto and it's like you
know if he could have just thrown money
at it and just done it that way he would
have told the story but it wouldn't have
had that he wouldn't have had that
poetic that poetic shot so
so all of this points to to me the
fascinating
collaborative quality that we all bring
our own talents we all bring our own
ways of seeing i feel this way when an
actor shows me something i never would
have imagined you know an actor i've had
experiences where you know i've fully
prepped i believe in that tremendously
how important it is for a director
to really explore as much as you can and
prep to really find out all the nuances
you think are there to figure out a
staging which i i prefer not to impose i
like the actors to find it but i but if
but i will tend to you know i will want
to make sure the staging is going to be
something that tells the story in
behavior as well as in the dialogue
so i can help guide the dire the actors
to finding that or if i have to if if
there are time constraints and i have to
impose a staging right away i can do it
i have it in my in my you know so i
you know i think being fully prepared
some some directors actually think well
no i want to be creative in the moment i
find i can be so much more creative in
the moment the more prepared i am
because i've thought about
what uh what is the key moment what is
the issue here and i've come up with a
solution to bring that about but if
someone comes up with a better solution
and i can plug o and i understand how
that will that will enhance this other
moment will actually deepen the meaning
i can employ it i can use it i can
incorporate it
so all of this is to say i guess that i
i so value uh
the collaboration that filmmaking
entails and as far as the writers not
you know they're within their rights not
to change the script they've you know
that they're performing their function
uh
if you're not a particularly talented
writer you may hamstring your
collaborators in ways that are
unfortunate but in this case i had very
talented writers alex gonza and ron
neiswaner i think was the writer for
this particular episode uh
it it they were tapping into a part of
their
unconscious i would say which is really
where creativity originates
and even though they weren't necessarily
conscious of the possibilities they they
you know revealed to me
i from my own experience was able to
discern
what i wanted to do with it
and how much do you consider the
audience especially for let's say a show
like home man where you said there were
other
uh episodes where that was really what
the audience wanted you know kind of
yeah you know um
yeah another really interesting fact
element to me of series directing
is
coming in as a director
one has to respect
the audience's prior experience and
their set of expectations so that can
manifest in several ways one of which is
say the visual language you know
you know i'm sure
everyone's favorite show has a
particular way of photographing things i
can remember in the i guess it was the
1990s how nypd blue made such a splash
because oh my goodness it's handheld
camera everywhere it's
shaking and it's like it's a documentary
oh that's so exciting it's like i'm
really there and you know and and
and you wouldn't pan for example
anticipating something from happening
because
if you were a documentarian you wouldn't
know that it was going to happen so you
wait for some character to talk and then
you go over to find them and it creates
a different subjective experience in the
audience and there are shows today that
became a staple for many kinds of shows
but as an example if i were hired to do
nypd blue which i i didn't have a good
fortune to work on
you know i can't come in and just say
okay we're just do this all in walk-offs
we're going to have elegant dolly moves
and you can't do that because
a you'd be fired but b
b even if you got through the episode
you would not be communicating the way
you thought you would think you'd be
communicating because the audience has a
different expectation so what you
what what you how you deviate from those
set those expectations are is
experienced as a deviation
so they're not just watching that as if
it's the first show they've ever seen
they're saying wait what's happening
it's eerie it's still it's still
you might put them in an alert state
wait that's not what i was trying to do
so you have to honor uh
uh everything and also the tone i i've
uh
feel very privileged uh to have directed
many different genres from it's always
sunny in philadelphia to the wire you
know and it's each each
each show has its own sensibility and
one of the things i really value about
what i get to do is i get to
immerse myself in different ways of
seeing but when i enter any show i have
to honor it and i have to fully absorb
its visual language it's tone it's
sensibility
how points are made
and uh
and and
you know that's if you don't do that
you're you're you're not serving the
story well you've mentioned that you
love robert bly yes
and so i have just a quote here where he
says the best presenters have
conversations with their audiences so
even if you can't let's say
have a conversation with the audience of
homeland or the wire
you you kind of know
the pulse of what they want yeah i told
you i think i didn't get to your
question so your question was
how much do i have to take into account
the audience right okay
um
yeah so an audience comes in with a set
of expectations and i and and you know
you don't tune into you know the
sopranos and want to watch you know uh
you know ballroom drama you know so it's
like if you it's like so you if you're
if you're providing it and and the
writers are generally you know almost
universally very aware of that so they
have we know we've gone too long without
a joke or we've gone too long without a
so-and-so
and so you have to plug into that
because if you don't you're you know
you're not serving the show
um and that and that tone that's where
tone can really uh
be a critical factor like for example
i'm trying to think i was a producer
director on the show big love which was
about
a polygamous household in utah mormon
the kind of the uh
what's the word the fundamentalist
morbid mormon community and
there were these wonderful actors in it
you know
uh bill pax and may rest in peace and
you know chloe 70 and you know
gene triple horn and it was just just a
you know wealth of people and all these
dramas happening as you can imagine with
three marriages and three wives and one
guy and all that stuff
but one thing i had to be very mindful
of which the producers were constantly
you know reinforcing is you know in utah
they're not a they're not a therapy
friendly
place people don't talk about their
emotions necessarily they don't display
their emotions a lot so even though a
scene might be rife with
rich
subtext you know if you're shooting it
in west los angeles where everybody's
been to therapy is perfectly happy to
reveal their feelings and i don't know
what you feel is what i feel that's not
that world
that's not that world so if you're not
attuned to the way you know so in a
shall we say even even repressed world
or certainly suppressed you know people
are very guarded and a lift eye lifted
eyebrow might be a very startling
startling thing to do you know so you
have to be sensitized to what
not just what the audience is expecting
but what the world you don't want to
betray the world of your story